et de l'or bonjour merci d'être avec
nous alors après un an et demi de
turbulences politiques de gestion
catastrophique également de la crise
sanitaire les bulgares retournent aux
urnes l'enjeu principal finalement c'est
de parvenir à un gouvernement stable
selon vous
oui oui l'enjeu c'est de parvenir à un
gouvernement stable
un gouvernement stable que là que la
bulgarie peine à trouver depuis 2013 en
réalité parce que ces élections seront
les sixièmes
depuis 2013 c'est-à-dire les sixième en
sept ans ce pays vit à la fois avec un
homme qui dominent la vie politique
depuis 2013 qui s'appelle boris
courbaron borisov qui est à la tête d'un
de ces partis qu'on appelait populis
qu'on appelle populiste sens très bien
savoir jamais ce que ce terme recouvre
et il est aujourd'hui doubler par
d'autres partis
mise en difficulté par d'autres partis
parce que son gouvernement a été son
dernier gouvernement a été touché par
d'immenses scandales de corruption et
notamment son bras droit et donc il a
été obligé de démissionner
alors qu'il a qui l'avait qu'il était au
gouvernement depuis les dernières
élections de 2017 il a été obligé de
démissionner par le mouvement de la rue
soutenu par le président de la
république puisque le président de la
république avait été élu grâce au
soutien de ses principaux opposants
socialistes
lors des dernières de la dernière
élection présidentielle
et donc depuis on a cette série de trois
scrutins dans lequel on a une montée des
oppositions
[Musique]
mais l'impossibilité pour les
oppositions de former un gouvernement de
coalition est ce que ça pourrait changer
cette fois ci on sait que pour l'instant
les sondages donnent
voilà le parti de borisov en tête les
centristes et les socialistes se
disputerait alors la deuxième place on
parle dans ce cas là de tractations pour
former un gouvernement de coalition
finalement ça va être un petit peu le
même scénario que lors des précédentes
élections
c'est ce qu'on craint c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui le
gerd de borisov est donnée août sur ou
autour de 25% mais 25 pour ça c'est pas
suffisant pour pour former un
gouvernement et de loin donc il faut que
borisov trouve des alliés les aline
ultranationaliste qu'il avait avant la
crise de 2021
ne sont plus au parlement depuis les
élections d'avril et il semble que ce
sera encore un peu juste pour eux d'y
rentrer à ces élections là il ya un
ancien chanteur
qui a formé trifonov qui a formé un
parti qui a connu une ascension
formidable puisque pour sa première
les premières élections auxquelles ils
participèrent en avril il a obtenu 17
40% puis
23%
24% aux élections de juillet en passant
devant le parti de borisov mais ce parti
a refusé toutes les alliances il a voulu
former un gouvernement minoritaire ce
qui a échoué et il se retrouverait
aujourd'hui en troisième ou quatrième
position alors les socialistes qui est l
opposition traditionnelle ne cesse de
baisser et on ne voit pas qui soient en
position de redresser la tête de manière
très importante et c'est le nouveau
parti donc parler votre reportage qui
comportait deux ministres de l'ère de
l'ancien
de l'ancien gouvernement de trop mission
qui s'appelle nous continuons le
changement c'est ce parti qui semble
devoir être en deuxième ou troisième
position mais on voit bien si vous
voulez comment l'électorat bulgare est
aujourd'hui comme beaucoup des lectorats
européens d'ailleurs et est aujourd'hui
totalement fluide c'est à dire que
la politique d'austérité
imposé par l'union européenne aux pays
de des balkans
la corruption du gouvernement bulgare
l'absence de véritables
le véritable alternative politique dans
le cadre de l'union européenne et la
gestion catastrophique du coc vides font
qu'on est dans une situation totalement
bloqué
merci beaucoup en tout cas olivier
delorme d'avoir réagir sur notre antenne
ce matin je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et écrivain